the agenda I want to push is that the
United States should stay out of it
financially yeah I do too yeah I at this
point especially but the but now Biden
wants to give $100 million so just
justifying the terror attack the Biden
Administration is trying to make both
sides happy and they will proceed to let
everyone down because they also issu
they're like we are issuing sanctions
against several members and entities
affiliated with Hamas so they are trying
to cover all their bases this is not
going to work the only option really
would be to not get involved but of
course they're just making us more
involved in ways that are so complicated
and are obviously going to backfire
Biden's going to strengthen his Base by
pumping money into any cause he can
related to helping Palestine and leftist
activists meanwhile conservatives in the
United States are going to scream for
Israel and dump more of the United
States dollars into Israel we already
give them billions of dollars we should
just stop giving everyone money we just
thoughts and prayers like we're not the
world's ATM we the reason we give them
money is so they spend it